joining us from New York is Anthony
scaramouche I served as White House
communications director was a 10 or 11
days let's get this on the record
straight well I sort of say 954 thousand
seconds now so that makes me feel better
but I I sort of think it was 11 days
let's begin with some news and thank you
very much for being with us this is the
headline from The Washington Times as
the president slamming the trade critics
saying that the US has been ripped off
for years he used Twitter yesterday
saying that basically there's an 800
billion dollar disparity between the US
and China and yet as we now are seeing
these tariffs with aluminum and steel
aimed at the European Union Canada and
Mexico do you worry that we are
alienating among our closest allies well
I mean let's just step back I think with
the president saying on the Twitter feed
is that sort of an accumulation of trade
deficit imbalances that have gone back
over let's say five to 15 years so it's
not exactly precise to say that it's 800
billion this year but you're making a
more broader point as it relates to our
allies and I think what the president's
trying to say to our allies and even our
potential competitors and adversaries is
that the United States has to reset the
way that we're involved with global
trade today and if we're going to help
the American worker and the middle-class
families and if we're going to increase
aggregate demand in our society which is
something we're having a hard time doing
you know if you look at the last twelve
years of wages wages have been stagnant
if you go back thirty five years they've
been stagnant and if you go to some of
these trade deals as you and I both know
after World War two we reordered the
trading field so that it would be
imbalanced against the United States and
we did that for very good reason we were
trying to create a global interdependent
economically interdependent middle class
which by and large has worked and it's
led to less global military conflict but
the deleterious outcome of that the bad
side effect of that is that we've lost
tons and tons of
manufacturing jobs wages in the United
States have been stagnant - downward as
other countries have built their labor
forces and so I think with the president
saying we step back allies and end
potential competitors we want free trade
we want that trade to be fair to the
United States now we can no longer
accept the imbalances he did send that
tweet out as well last night talking
about how we're not charging anybody for
goods and services that are flowing into
the US but yet we are willing to accept
embargoes and other nations and so we we
have to sort of knock that off now if we
want to protect American workers and so
I think that's the point I think that's
the point that's being missed in the
whole conversation the the tower of
threat is a cudgel in the negotiation to
try to get people to the table and to
recognize that the system that's in
place right now which has been primarily
in place for the last 75 years is no
longer workable for the US the president
will be attending the g7 summit in
Canada and then heading on to Singapore
but let me get your reaction to an
interview that aired this morning on
NBC's Meet the Press and Chuck Todd
traveling to Ottawa Canada with this
line of questioning to Justin Trudeau
the Canadian Prime Minister idea that
you know our soldiers who had fought and
died together on the beaches of world
war 2 on the and the mountains of
Afghanistan had have stood
shoulder-to-shoulder in some of the most
difficult places in the world that are
always there for each other somehow this
is insulting to them the idea that the
Canadian steel that's in military
military vehicles in the United States
the Canadian aluminum that makes your
your fighter jets is somehow now a
threat the fact that I mean next week
we're hosting at the g7 summit of world
leaders and the airfield the military
base that Air Force Ones going to land
in was put there in World War two to
protect an aluminum smelter that was
providing to the military effort the
idea that we are somehow a national
security threat to the United States is
quite frankly insulting and
acceptable so what do you feel as if the
president wants from you and putting
these tears out there I don't know you
don't know what he wants here you don't
know is this about is about Annapolis
you don't you don't have an I don't know
is because he's talked about the fact of
this he's worried about trade surpluses
trade deathless deficits around the
world well they have a two billion
dollar surplus on steel with us so it's
not like the the the trade is imbalanced
against the US favor on them from NBC's
Meet the Press one of the five Sunday
shows that we air on c-span radio
beginning at noon Eastern Time every
Sunday afternoon and Anthony Sierra
Moochie reference to the National
Security clause which the president is
using to impose these tariffs on Canada
and other countries well listen I have a
lot of respect for the Prime Minister I
understand what he's doing is easy
he's a very iterative politician and so
he's spinning it just a little bit
because when the president is talking
about national security it's not an
existential threat from China I'm sorry
from Canada what it is is it's just
looking at the map of our steel iron and
aluminum production and it is
dramatically shrunk and he does not want
it to shrink any further moreover he
wants her to be an increase in market
share there and you've heard him
probably say this from the stump more
than one time if you don't have steel or
aluminum you don't have a country and so
it's less about Canada per se and it's
more about the whole global situation on
how we've allowed this manufacturing
base this element of our manufacturing
to erode but the Canadian Prime Minister
is correct we have a wonderful
relationship with Canada we our trading
partners or obviously our best if not in
the top two or three trading partners in
the world and we need to figure out a
way to keep that relationship as
harmonious as possible and I think he
does know and I think his trade
negotiators know as it relates to the
renegotiation of NAFTA that there's a
lot of fairness and in the president's
proposal so if we can dial back the
rhetoric and I know this is something
that politicians have to do they feel
compelled to you know the president says
something they feel compelled that they
have to defend their constituents and
their labor force and they need to say
something but if we can take it to a
back room and just go line by line
through these trade agreements what
we'll discover is that where the things
are unfair to the United States let's
make them a little fairer if there
happened to be unfair to the Canadians
believe it or not President Trump wants
to make it more fair he is for and I've
heard him say this hundreds of times
remember I was on the campaign with him
for two years I was on his transition
team although I was only in the White
House for a short period of time I'm
very close to the economic team there
and the president's commitment is to
freer trade and more goods and services
flowing globally around the world but we
need to no longer accept the embargoes
and the quotas and I want to just tell
your viewers one thing quickly had
Chrysler been able to sell grand
cherokees into Japan at the population
proportion demand that they had in 2008
they never would have had to go on
bankrupt and so we need to clear this up
we need to clean it up and I appreciate
what the prime minister saying on behalf
of his country and his citizens but he
also knows line by line where there's
elements of unfairness on either side
let's make them fair and let's make it
symmetrical those listening on c-span
radio and on Sirius XM the POTUS channel
124 our guest is ethany Sierra Moochie
served as White House communications
director also former chief strategy
officer for the export-import bank
he is the founder of skybridge capital
he's joining us from Southampton New
York and let me get you to react to some
other news on this Sunday morning I'm
sure you saw the story yesterday in the
New York Times it is front page today
the president is exempt from questions
that according to his lawyer and let me
just share part of what the New York
Times is reporting today quote president
Trump's lawyers have for months quietly
waged a campaign to keep the special
counsel from trying to force him to
answer questions in the investigation
into whether he obstructed justice in a
branch assertion of presidential power
this 20 page letter or memo that was
sent to robert muller the special
counsel contends
the president cannot illegally obstruct
any aspect of the investigation into
Russia's election meddling because the
Constitution empowers him to quote if he
wished to terminate the inquiry or even
exercise his presidential power and
authority to pardon mr. Trump's lawyers
fear that he answers questions either
voluntarily or in front of a grand jury
he does risk exposing himself to
accusations of lying to investigations
and that potentially is a crime of
impeachable offense your reaction you
want me to react that okay so so I hear
your here's what I would say I haven't
seen the letter so I'm not going to be
able to react to the specifics that are
in the letter but I can react more
broadly to the legal strategy and more
broadly to the thought behind where the
president's legal team is going I think
there's a there's three elements there
the first element is you obviously want
him to be open to being interviewed
because you don't want anybody to feel
that there was any level of obstruction
of justice on behalf of the President or
any members of his staff and so they
sort of in the beginning wanted that
door open secondarily they want to be
very very careful here because under
oath obviously they don't want the
president to make a misstatement you
know I'm going to say that their
accidental misstatements his adversaries
are going to say that their intentional
misstatements but if you're the
president's lawyer you don't want them
to make one whether it's accidental or
intentional and then the third issue
here is the assertion of presidential
power you had my old constitutional law
professor on in the last hour he has
probably a different view of the powers
of the presidencies and say Rudy
Giuliani does but one thing that's
absolutely clear when you get to the
line of overexertion of presidential
power it can cause a high level of
disruption if you just think about what
happened with Archibald Cox 44 or 45
years ago you don't want to put the
president in the position where he's
firing anybody as it relates to this
investigation so I think they're just
trying to
lay out some negotiating terms on how
they want to work with the special
prosecutor's team and my guess is is
that there'll be people upset about that
letter but I think from a legal strategy
the letter makes sense because they want
to protect the president they want to
protect the president from you know
again unintentional miscues that could -
what you just said earlier be brought in
a case of perjury which obviously the
president doesn't want to do how long
have you known Donald Trump well known
him known him super well I would say
over the last six years met him for the
first time probably 21 22 years ago when
I was still a vice president at Goldman
Sachs and so my old boss Mike Fassett le
introduced me to then mr. Trump at the
Trump Tower in 1995 but I didn't know
him I can't say that I was a good friend
of his we became closer after the
governor Mitt Romney campaign for the
presidency and we did a number of
fundraisers in mr. Trump's apartment on
behalf of Governor Romney and believe it
or not mr. Trump even participated in a
calleth on that we hosted for the
governor late in 2012 so I know I'm
pretty well let's go to Lisa joining us
from Shreveport Louisiana Republican
line with Anthony Sierra Moochie who's
joining us from New York
oh and I'm so excited
anyway what I want you to I want to talk
see what just let me finish okay number
one Russia did not interfere in election
all they've been doing it forever number
two do you think that present Trump will
be classified everything where we can
find out exactly what the Obama
administration did in spying and also do
you think John Brennan clapeyron and
will be charged and number three Anthony
I got to meet Cory Lewandowski in
Shreveport Louisiana when they came down
with their book and they were great and
I will be going to Washington to see
President Trump get reelected and I will
be one of the people in the biggest
crowd that will ever be thank you thank
you Lisa Anthony
a year response all right well okay well
at least it's great to hear your voice
um and Cory is a great guy by the way
but but I here's what I would say I I
don't think that I think it was Brennan
and clapper John and Brennan and John
clapper I do not think that they're
going to be charged I do think that
something happened there some people
want to call it an informant other
people want to call it spying but I do
think what's necessary is to have an
Inspector General look at this stuff and
try to look at it objectively what I'm
very saddened by is that these are
institutions that we hold sacred in the
country and these are institutions that
are supposed to be executing the rule of
law and what we know about our great
Republican democracy is that all of us
are below that meaning all of us are
beneath the rule of law and have to be
subjected to it and so I really do not
hope that these agencies were weaponized
against the President or weaponized
against individual or potentially
innocent citizens and so we'll see that
unfold over the next three to six months
so I'm not exactly sure what's going to
happen there but I don't see those two
gentlemen getting in trouble as much as
they may have been part of something
that you know it smells a little bit too
partisan from this vantage point but
well we'll have to see how it altima Lee
happens but I do agree with you Lisa
that the president is going to be
resoundingly reelected in 2020 he's done
nothing wrong I was on that campaign for
like I said two years there was no
collusion that I was aware of I know the
president's personality he wears
everything on his sleeve it would be
very hard for him to hide something like
that from his senior staff and the last
point I would like to make is the
economy is doing very very well and if
you go across sections of the United
States and you think about the optimism
that's in the economy today it would be
hard for me to see a scenario where the
president doesn't get reelected but that
doesn't mean we're not going to all be
working super hard on his bass playing
like we did last time like we are we
were the underdogs in the situation do
you think Governor Kasich or Senator
flake will challenge him in a Republican
primary
yeah I think it's possible if you listen
to them I I don't know either of them
personally but I've seen their
interviews it is possible they may want
to do something like that I hope that
they don't do something like that
because it's it's bad for the Republican
Party we're all wearing the same Jersey
we may have differences in personality
differences in personality styles but
were roughly getting everything right
Warren Buffett has a great line I'd
rather be roughly right than precisely
wrong and I think it would be precisely
wrong for those two guys to challenge
President Trump in a primary but if they
do do that it will not have the effect
that Ted Kennedy had on Jimmy Carter or
the effect that Ronald Reagan had on
Gerald Ford in 1976
so say they'll they'll be defeated it'll
be an ugly battle unfortunately but it's
not going to really affect the long-term
prospects of the president's reelection
capability in the collar making
reference to John Brennan former CIA
director he has a piece this morning
Anthony scaramouche II into the
Washington Post and Oval Office without
integrity and he says the following the
impact of the Trump presidency will be
felt for many years to come most
worrisome is his use of falsehoods his
mean-spirited and malicious behavior and
his self-absorption which will be
emulated by many Americans reaction
unless I mean they're they're they're
rough on each other right now these guys
are two titans that are swinging very
hard at each other director Brennan is
somebody I actually do know I I've met
him a few times and I invited him in
2017 to speak at my investor conference
and then we had a small dinner for him I
have a lot of respect for him as an
American and I and I and if I were
talking to the president directly what I
would say is that John Brennan was
instrumental in really rolling back and
really executing a lot of the
anti-terrorist campaign and programs
both inside the United States and
outside the United States after 9/11 and
so he saved legions of American lives
and an innocent citizens abroad
but I think what happens is and this has
happened to me unfortunately it happens
to many people we get our egos into the
situation we get our ire up a little bit
and then we go at loggerheads with each
other and so I hope I hope that stops I
do think that the war declaration on the
media is not helping the president I've
said that to the president personally I
have no problem saying it here on c-span
he's better than that he's bigger than
that for 15 years he was a television
star and there's no reason why he can't
come on c-span or be re interviewed by
Lester Holt or any of the other major
news outlets and to get his voice back
out there because I think what people
will see about the president is that
it's a way more moderating voice than
the voice that's being pigeon-holed
right now and being described by
director Brennan so listen we're in a
rough-and-tumble country right now is it
relates to our politics I've experienced
that in some ways I was a minor casualty
of that but I do hope that all sides
will dial it back a little bit and let's
find our selves as the true Americans
that we are we have way more in common
with each other than then we have
against each other and I do think by and
large that the president will eventually
do that but I just feel he's he feels
under the gun by his adversaries and
frankly he likes punching back in a
situation like that and if you were on
the campaign playing with him when he
was tweeting stuff that people thought
was quote-unquote on presidential he
would remark well this is the way
unfortunately I'm gonna have to be if I
want to win this race and so it's an
ugly time in certain ways in American
politics and it would be better for
everybody to take a step back and
recognize that we have more in common
then separates us the president still
does not have a communications director
does he need one and if asked would you
return to the White House okay so I you
know you had professor tribe on an hour
ago and one of the things he taught me
back then was you can't really answer
hypotheticals like that because you
always get yourself in trouble but but I
I don't see myself being as
back to the White House and so I don't
really think I'm gonna have to weigh
that decision but what I will say is in
the last nine months since I departed or
10 months as I departed I'm back at
skybridge Capital the company that I
founded and we're growing that business
and the performance has been great and
it would be very tough for me right now
to dislodge myself from the firm that I
went back to but but uh it would be
flattering to be asked back there's no
question about that but I see that
possibility of me being asked back to
the White House and about minus five
hundred percent so that's that's my
thoughts on that well go to Jerry in
Huntsville Alabama Democrats line we're
talking with Anthony scare Moochie good
morning Jerry even more how you guys
doing today I have a two quick points I
want to make turn out as a Army veteran
of 28 years you know integrity and
ethics means a lot to me and clearly
this president doesn't having tyranny
you know I'm not like a lot of Democrats
calling for Pietschmann
you know elections do have consequences
so the American people just have to deal
with this ID for the next few years
and if 2020 is my sounding board
nothing will thank you have a nice day
Thank You Jerry yeah listen I mean that
that that expressed Jerry's expression
is an expression that's out there and so
we've also colorized a situation with
the way we've segmented our media and so
a lot of us myself included we sometimes
go to the television channels that
confirm our own biases so I I would
disagree respectfully with Jerry that I
don't see the president has an unethical
person I see the president as an
aggressive person I see the president as
a person that is willing to use the
force of his personality to get get
things done but I don't I don't see the
on ethics there and I work very closely
with them Sharon is next Southside West
Virginia good morning Republican line hi
good morning thank you oh good morning
auntie scary meaty it's good to see you
I have
to comment also about the Russia
collusion it looks like to me that the
collusion was with the Democrats and it
backfired on them and also the
mainstream media keeps saying that Trump
should be grateful that the FBI spied on
him that's crazy so those are my
comments have a great Thank You Sharon
well I mean I'll address both I mean I
think that the the thing of the
President had swore about and this is
something that he tweeted about last
week I actually commented about it as
well is that if there was an informant a
spy whatever you want to call it if
there was this fear about Russian
potentiality of conclude collusion or
Russian meddling in the in the campaign
or the overall presidential election
it's hard to understand how they
wouldn't have gone to the candidate and
briefed him and so I say this to
everybody and say it please think about
it objectively if it were Jeb Bush if it
were John Kasich
if it was somebody that the
establishment in Washington felt was
part of their ilk what they had briefed
him and I'm asking that rhetorically but
it was because it was an outsider and a
business person with a brash television
personality a television star that they
probably didn't feel was in their
kumbaya circle if you will that's
probably why they didn't brief him and
so I think that was very unfair to the
president when he was a candidate and so
we have to see how that situation
unfolds on the first topic I guess the
only the only thing I can say to you is
I was around the hoop and so were many
others I didn't see anything that the
FBI as it related to president Trump
would be concerned about and even trey
gowdy
who's dismissing some of the allegations
of spying in his last several interviews
has said publicly that from everything
that he's read and seen that the
president is not a target of this
investigation so
I think that's good news for president
Trump as well this program is carried on
the BBC Parliament channel and carried
live every Sunday afternoon in Great
Britain Kevin is joining us from London
England
good afternoon Kevin high grass news
before we start on a light note we're
very glad to have a new American
princess just a light now they're now
getting down to the bit of the daily
business of politics what we don't
understand over here in Europe is how
the leader of a nation continually
attacks his own staff and this just
doesn't go well with anything nobody
understands you wouldn't want this in
your workplace so when the president
continually attacks his own stuff no
democrat stuff his own stuff
what sort of leadership is that and in
really confused Kevin thank you of
course we saw that most recently with
his disdain over Jeff Sessions the
Attorney General Anthony scaramouche
your response well you have to you have
to look at the origin of the president
is operating in management style he grew
up in a builder's family a real estate
development family it's a very hard
knuckled rough-and-tumble din vironment
in New York City real estate he built a
magnificent tower in 1980 when no one
thought it could be done on that
specific location and if you if you go
to the Netflix documentary not which I
think was done by News 4 which is a
British news channel you could see that
it was a very rough and tumble
environment that the president was
creating his career in and so one aspect
of his personality some people don't
like it but I've said to my colleagues
even in the short stint that I was in
the White House when he was hitting
people on Twitter or he was being
critical of his associates or staff what
I said to my colleagues I'll say it here
on c-span you need a very thick skin to
work with the president you also need to
know that the the president will
sometimes be saying things to you the
way a rough football coach would be
saying things to you at a halftime
speech and so you you can't overly
absorb that and you can't overly think
Oh
my god you know I should run out the
door right now you should say okay he's
a tough love sort of a person the way
frankly my high school football coach
was and you either have the personality
where you can take that or not but
here's the thing the president going to
be 72 years old on June 15th which is
American flag day he's not changing
that's his personality and I would tell
people that work for them or people that
have been around them you got to roll
with it and so I hear you it's probably
not in a management book at the Harvard
Business School or the London Business
School in terms of the protocol but it
is what it is and so you know I would
suggest to the people working with them
to adapt to it if they want to stay
working with too personal notes first of
all the mooch is that a relatively new
nickname or did you grow up with that
not you know I grew up with that so I
think it's funny because here the
liberals love using the mooch because
it's apparently a pejorative like you
know you you're mooching off of people
one of my kids said I should be called
mooched because I'm always being mooched
off of but that's fine my last name is
scare Moochie so I remember being called
the mooch or mooch from like the early
70s when I was a kid so I don't mind the
nickname at all if you go on Amazon
either some guy selling mooch t-shirts
which are an absolute riot so I don't I
hope he sold a lot of them to be honest
but there's some funny t-shirts out
there with my nickname on we'll have our
producer Glyn Lee Smith looked that up
but let me ask you about this other
story that broke a couple weeks ago the
possibility of you and Michael avenatti
co-hosting a program on MSNBC or CNN
anything new on that front would you
co-host a program with him you know I
mean the truth of the matter is Michael
and avenatti and I met at J sources a
yeah there you go there's a picture I
had a how to get my fist up there just
so that you could see there's a little
bit of a Kemetic rivalry they are among
everything else but you know I don't
know Michael well I do think Michael is
a formidable competitor there's no
question that Michael is the kind of guy
I've seen him on TV and he's a Detroit
very skillful guy
he has a real presence and so he would
be the type of guy that I would want on
my team frankly having said that I want
him to be defeated in the courtroom
because of what's going on there what I
have a show with him you know nothing
has ever really come up of that you know
that's sort of the funny thing and it's
the unfortunate thing I've learned in
the last year I've read so many
different things about myself in my life
in gossip pages or tabloid areas I was
like gosh that's not true or or this
isn't true there was one woman out there
writing that she saw me come off of Air
Force One and she saw my luggage stack
and I have to be five foot two and so
I'm actually not five foot two I'm five
nine but that's fine you know as a lot
of people think I'm five foot two I'm
sitting on four phone books here in this
studio in Southampton to talk to you
guys just so you know my feet are
dangling but my point is a lot of stuff
that isn't true there's been no real
discussion about that but I do respect
Michael avenatti and I would tell lawyer
opposing lawyers don't underestimate him
he's definitely got a strategic sense
and he's obviously got a very good
communication skill but bottom line
interested or intrigued by the
possibility down the road of doing a
program with him you know I mean when if
it were to come to pass where somebody
actually laid out a proposal and I could
see what the guidelines were I'm open to
a lot of different things I get I guess
that the the one the one thing I don't
want is a show that's going to detract
from my existing business at skybridge
and so if I didn't do it it would
probably be more related to that not
wanting to do anything that would hurt
our existing business and one other
follow-up if you had your choice of a
network that it would be on CNBC Fox
MSNBC or CNN do prize why not why not
c-span you guys haven't you don't you
don't have any room for us on a channel
we have room you can both come back next
week as a matter of fact we'd love to
have you and by the way we found a
t-shirt by the way remembering a
relative them out there yeah there's a
remember
their moods is a stay calm and let mood
channel it there's a mooch starter pack
which has my women sunglasses which I
was wearing in the White House I mean
look it's all good I had a roll with the
punches we've got a Jeffrey and
Greendale in there that picket
go ahead Jeffrey on the Democrats line
good morning I had the Anthony talk
about some of the things that people who
defend the president talk about hard
knocker rough-and-tumble aspects of his
personality and the way he was brought
up in New York and then he goes on to
talk about you know no collusion he like
the rest of them one talk to suspend our
sense of reasoning and you know not
believe our lyin eyes let me ask you
Anthony you said you are not aware of
any thing that the president has done
why do you have to qualify it by saying
you're not away you know there's you
know what they call it and review that
is being done you know of the people
that have been invited and you people
keep on saying this in 20 years has said
that the president is a bully for eight
years he was bullying in President Obama
and you're coming to defend this man
with all the things that you have been
seeing that he has been doing please
save us you know all that Russia
concerns that you do Thank You Jeffrey
well III get the argument on the other
side and I and I get I get I understand
why you're upset but but here's here's
what I would say when I when I say I'm
not aware of I was saying frankly that
there was no collusion and so people
were saying to me well you actually
don't 100% know that you haven't been in
every single meeting you weren't on
every single campaign trip on the
campaign you weren't on every single
phone call so you can't say that there
was quote-unquote no collusion so that's
why I've qualified it but if you're
really asking me my gut I really don't
believe that there was any collusion so
so but you know I understand what you're
saying or your
well he's a rough-and-tumble guy and so
therefore he has had to have cross the
line into treason and criminality and so
I'm sorry I just not going to accept
that I think that the president despite
what people think about him I was
listening to BBC BBC Worldwide this
morning there was a woman from Shanghai
on there saying well the guy president
Trump loves strong men he loves Putin
and he loves President Xi and Chairman
Kim and so on and so forth and you know
all of that is really not true you know
he is a very good negotiator he wants
there to be peace and prosperity
globally in the world
he went to Davos Switzerland to try to
send people a message that he wants to
be integrated into the global system but
he also wants to look out for American
workers so so look it he's got an
unorthodox style you know there was a
guy in MSNBC yesterday after I left the
show and he was trying to he was trying
to say that we meaning me and Donald
Trump have New York values you know this
sort of nonsense and and the truth of
the matter is we can have a different
operating style but still be very honest
and fair and ethical with dealing with
people so so I don't have to say when
you say don't don't believe your lying
eyes III don't see it that way you know
I I know the President as I've said for
pretty closely for five or six years and
this is not a guy that would do
something treasonous with the Russians I
just don't see it so you can dislike me
saying that but I mean they continue
saying that until we have definitive
proof otherwise which I predict will
never happen and the president just a
short while ago tweeting again Anthony
scaramouch Ian let me just share with
you what he wrote at real Donald Trump
as only one of two people left who could
have become president why would the FBI
or the Department of Justice and he puts
justice in quotes have told me that they
were secretly investigating Paul
Manafort on charges that were 10 years
old and had been previously dropped
during my campaign question mark should
have told me
exclamation mark any reaction
well I mean again that's along the line
this is one of the fun parts about being
the the president's comes a retribution
you never knew when the incoming tweet
missile was going to land on your desk
so but but here's what I would say to
you that this is along the lines of what
we were saying earlier about the implant
the informant the spy whatever whatever
you're talking about why wouldn't they
let him know if there was something like
this and I think you know one of the
reasons why he's moving on the pardons
is that it appears to him and it appears
to many people in the United States that
there's been a weaponization of some of
these agencies and some of these
departments and things have crossed over
into criminality that weren't
necessarily criminal but it's a way to
push out or eviscerate your political
opponents and so so I think he's trying
to send a message to people that hey
listen to people left to be President I
sort of thought I would be briefed on
things like this particularly if I had
nefarious people or at least people that
you thought were nefarious inside my
campaign and so I think he has a valid
point there it'll be interesting to see
the spin process this week now and the
reaction and overreaction to that tweet
but at the end of the day and I would
say this to Professor tribe and anybody
else that's that's out there put
yourself in the other person's shoes for
a little while and see where they live
and I think you'll have some respect
from where he's coming from our next
caller from New Jersey Louis on the
Republican line good morning morning hey
Steve how are you
we're fine hey good morning Hugh Anthony
the morning is timeless
Losey and all the other Democratic
leaders basically beating each other off
to get to the microphone to pursue this
collusion theory and now all you hear
from them is that they don't want to
release documents because it's national
security I mean you don't hear from
these guys anymore and on the other hand
this time last year Brennan
clapper didn't hear anything from the
vehm because they didn't think the show
was gonna fall on them and by the way
whatever happened to combs everyday was
out there now you only hear from them
because she knows the shoes gonna drop
Thank You Louis and there is an ID
report on the investigation coming out
in the coming weeks we're told Anthony
Sierra Moochie well listen i mean the
the IG bro I haven't seen any of it but
I mean the IG report and would happen
with one of commis deputy directors
Andrew McCabe I think that there's a lot
of speculation in Washington that
certain things happened improperly so I
I don't want to react to that because
these are longtime civil servants and
they've served the country and so I want
to give them the benefit of the doubt
like I would like people to give the
president the benefit of the doubt we
need levels of due process in the
country before we start the you know the
accusations and the the guilt aspersions
but but you know it does seem and in in
director Comey's case I think that there
the problem there when you're talking
about higher loyalty and you're being
interviewed on the BBC and the woman is
asking you well knowing what you know
now about president Trump would you be
handing over intelligence briefings to
him and he says he's not going to do
that you what are you talking about I
mean you know there's a rule of law in
the country you may not like the guy you
may not like his personality but he's
the president United States and so
there's a protocol and a procedure that
has to take place whether you like it or
not or try to remove the guy from office
using the Constitution right books like
Professor tribe but but I I think these
guys are a little bit too sanctimonious
they're probably a little bit too
righteous
and I and I think that they don't have
him in the box of meaning president
Trump that they thought they had him in
because he's not the kind of guy they're
they're confusing his style and they're
confusing his at times bombast without
really understanding the full
fundamentals of his content and I think
that's a big mistake so the content is
absolutely perfect and you know
sometimes the style can get out there
and upset people I've seen more than one
person in the last two years that
suffers from Trump derangement syndrome
and so these guys have a little bit of
it frankly I want to be precise with
this did you call it incoming Twitter
missiles is that the phrase you used
yeah yeah into like income I mean you
know you're sitting there like okay
let's have a comms plan and then the
president's his home comms director he's
firing in these these missiles I mean
I'm you know look I don't want to speak
on behalf of Sarah or anybody else on
the comms team but you know there's a
little bit of a you know humorous thing
about all that you know I mean hope and
I used to find that very humorous you
know at the end of the day the point
being you were talking about him hiring
a futurecom sir Ector you need somebody
that knows the president somebody that
likes the president is not put off by
the president's style and also can deal
with the unpredictability of what he's
doing because he's a very intuitive guy
and you know we we had a campaign event
back in 2016 at chip rihanna's which is
on 42nd Street in and I really wish I
had recorded this but we had it at chip
Rihanna's at a large group there and the
president then the candidate had h1 I
would say a 15 minute soliloquy on his
Twitter strategy which I thought was
just like absolutely brilliant and
should end up in like a Harvard Business
School case study in terms of how he was
deploying Twitter on the campaign you
know this was early this was stole or he
had gotten the nomination how he was
deploying and why he was deploying it
and the way that he was and how
effective it was in terms of him getting
his message out and so you know one of
the reasons why he tweets like that is
he knows places like C's
an NBC CNBC MSNBC all of the media
groups Fox have to put out his his
Twitter statement and force a reaction
so yeah their incoming Twitter missiles
and I'm just glad to let you know there
is no anti-ballistic missile defense
that's going to be developed to
counteract those because another one
just came in so let's get your reaction
this is from the president again right
following up on Paul Manafort he said
Paul Manafort came into the campaign
very late and was with us for a short
period of time he represented Ronald
Reagan Bob Dole and many others over the
years but we should have been told that
Comey and the boys were doing a number
on him and he would not have been hired
yeah I mean I mean listen I I know Paul
well and I have a I have a lot of
respect for Paul Paul says he's innocent
let's let that process take its place in
the court system I think why the
president brought Paul in is if you guys
remember back at that moment there was a
discussion about him winning all the
primaries or the majority of the
primaries but potentially getting
hijacked at the convention where the
delegates there were going to swap their
votes and so forth and so Paul Manafort
from the mid 20s there's a great book
about the 1980 and the 1976 conventions
where Paul Manafort is there helping
Ronald Reagan aggregate size up the
convention delegates to get him to the
nomination etc and so it was recommended
to President Trump to bring him in and
you know they got along well and so when
Cory left the campaign he made him
campaign manager temporarily and then
you know as they got through the
convention process I think the president
wanted to go in a different direction
and that's why you hired Kellyanne
Conway and Steve ban and I think that
was probably August of 2016
but the president's making a point where
if if you're getting briefed you're
you're down to being one of the one or
two last people in the race and why not
give me the heads-up
he's also being a little cheeky there
when he's saying that because he knows
they weren't going to give him the heads
up and he's just trying to call out the
level of unfairness there and I would
just say to people that are adversaries
of the president stylistically dial back
some of your righteousness and
sanctimony you'll probably do a little
bit better you know if you get too
emotionally charged you're gonna end up
losing a lot of the American people I
mean you know I you know it's just it's
just nonsense at this point we welcome
our radio listeners Tom is joining us
from Hollywood Florida Democrats line
with Anthony's care Moochie good morning
tom hi just one the thing I find mr.
spera Mochis comments on president
Trump's ethics that laughable I've been
watching it for over four years he
doesn't have any but what I wanted to
talk about were these statements in the
press about how the President's powers
now say that he can terminate any
federal investigation he could get rid
of Moeller and he's totally that would
leave and totally above the law so
what's next is he going to eliminate
term limits and elevate himself to
dictator okay all right well obviously
he does have the power to fire the
prosecutor and so Richard Nixon did that
with Archibald Cox he ended up with Leon
Jaworski it was it was not it's not it's
not a good thing to do it wouldn't be a
strategy that I would recommend friends
of the president probably would not
recommend that strategy even perhaps in
some levels of frustration where he's
suggested it or brainstormed about it I
would I would tell you that it's never
really been an option it's never really
been something that was going to be
deployed you're making the point where
that he doesn't have any ethics so we we
could sort of debate that but you know
probably don't have enough time on this
television show but here's what I would
say to you whatever you think of the
president and whatever I think of the
president the American people in 2016
voted him president there were over 63
and a half million people that voted for
him that wanted him to be their
president and whatever the Surgeon
General
warning label was on president Trump's
life I mean he was 70 71 years old at
the time and so you could see the full
array of things that he's done in his
life the positive negative those things
the American people said okay I'm not
looking for the perfect person I'm
looking for somebody and I've only got
two choices I'm looking for the best of
the two choices that he's gonna do the
best job for the American people so he
is president he's not looking to be
above the rule of law but he's looking
for the law to be practiced fairly as it
relates to him and I think what he's
also seen which he's frustrated by he
does believe this that there's been
elements of the legal system that had
been weaponized to go after political
adversaries and so he feels that that's
the case in his case and that's why he's
pushing back on Twitter and and pushing
back in other areas but you know again
we'll debate this but he's not looking
to beat the dictator or anything like
that
I'm sure he'll serve out is two
four-year terms and it he'll move back
to one of his great homes if you were in
the White House now I want to ask you
about Scott Pruett the EPA director
another story this morning this is front
page of the New York Times the EPA chief
has cozy ties with a coal Baron and here
are some of the details mr. Pruitt's
mostly behind the scenes relationship
with Joseph W Kraft the third a
billionaire coal executive is emblematic
of his unorthodox approach to leading
the EPA where he often blurs the lines
between personal and official
relationships and has created the
impression at times that he does the
bidding of the industries the agency
regulates do you think he is a problem
for this administration well you know
it's not it doesn't really matter
whether I think he's a problem or not
it's ultimately up to the president the
president has got to look at the the
situation related to mr. Pruit and
decide whether or not it's a problem one
of the things I said earlier on the
program is you know and and I'm not
calling it fake news or false news or
anything like that I'm just saying that
we have to make sure when we're reading
the stuff that it is accurate and it is
objectively factual so in
in this case let me just see to the New
York time to say everything that they're
writing is objectively factual and if
that is the case then I would tell you
that you know you live down there not me
I mean that's why they call it the swamp
I mean I find a lot of the nefarious
activity that goes on inside of
Washington to be absolutely disgusting
and I think most of Americans do frankly
you know you're down there to serve the
public you've been given this special
trust where you should have a bond with
the American people and you should be
trying to think about these things in a
way that's going to serve the most
amount of the American people and less
about serving yourself so if this stuff
is true and the president asks for his
resignation I won't be surprised and if
it's true and the president doesn't ask
him for his resignation somebody will
eventually ask the president as to why
and you know you'll go get president
Trump's answer which is way more
valuable than mine quick question about
the White House briefing John Spicer was
with us a few weeks ago and he basically
said the daily briefing with Sarah
Huckabee Sanders is no longer useful
agree or disagree
I couldn't disagree more with that you
know and I understand why Sean would be
saying that because he moved to a non
camera brief briefing and you know he
had like a voice recording briefing
going on before I got there I think that
the American people sort of want that
and I also think if you even look at the
original construction of the documents
for the United States and you look at
what was written by our founders related
to the Free Press it is absolutely
imperative that we have a free press
control a checking the people that are
in power and so for me one of the first
things I did perhaps the only thing I
did in my short stint there of any major
consequence was I turned the lights and
cameras back on in that press room and
so when I arrived on that day I said the
cameras and lights are going back on the
president asked me to do that press
conference on that day and I said no
problem I'm happily to do that we then
got into a conversation about Sarah
Huckabee he asked me my feelings about
her and whether or not we should make
the temporary press secretary or the
permanent one I think Sarah is
absolutely fabulous I think she does an
amazing job for the president it's one
of the hardest jobs in Washington if not
the world and I said to the president in
the Oval Office that I had no problem
making her the permanent press secretary
and so he said okay great well let's
make her the permanent press secretary
and then when I left the Oval Office and
I went back to the the comms area I had
a conversation with Sarah I said listen
I'm gonna do the press conference today
because the president wants me to but I
promise you that'll be the last time I
do it I didn't realize I was getting
fired ten days later so that was a
definitely a fact but but I the point
being is that she's very very good at
that
and you have to remember I'm a I'm a
business executive I've started and run
successfully two companies and I know
how to delegate and I know how to make
sure that people you know you put
yourself when you're a business leader
into a servant leader position with
people and you try to help those people
maximize who they are and so in Sarah's
case I think she's done a brilliant job
of that she's a great person and I think
Shawn's wrong about that because at the
end of the day they got to take those
questions however hard those questions
are it's important for the American
people to see somebody that's
representing the president out there
accountable to the press that whatever
the meanness is whatever the
partisanship is whatever the biases may
be it's very very important for the
American people to see that and so I
strongly disagree with that and I hope
they keep these things going and even if
Sarah decides at some point that she's
gonna do something in the private sector
or help you know at home whatever to do
whoever takes her job I hope they
maintain that that example and they
continue to do that John good morning
joining us from Center Ossipee
New Hampshire you're on the phone with
Anthony square Moochie you know it's
good morning and thank you for taking my
call I just have a few quick car and
just notations that mr. skur Moochie
seems to have even forgotten or as left
out of his uh statements that this
morning one is Trump campaign was Warren
and 2016 I think was June by the FBI to
watch out for Russian interference and
at that point after that view perhaps
the indictments that have taken place a
certain person with certain campaign
individuals from the campaign / mr.
Trump had been indicted or lying to the
FBI number one - from meeting with
Russians and also we've got nine
Russians indicted we'll get a response
thank you John okay so the the June 2015
thing I wasn't aware of and so it's not
that I forgot that or I was trying to
spin anybody so I wasn't aware of that I
when I leave here or I'll google that
and try to get myself up to speed on it
as it relates to the the people that
were quote-unquote indicted related to
the campaign I didn't meet any of those
people so I I don't even know these
people personally but it seemed like the
charges that were being brought about
them we're less about Russian collusion
and more about perjury in lying to the
FBI but again maybe I don't I don't know
what I'm talking about there as it
relates to Russia I've said this I've
said this on a number of different
networks I'm probably even gonna say it
in my book as it relates to Russia the
Russians it appears have tried to meddle
and use some level of their intelligence
forces in elections around the world not
just in the United States I frankly
don't think that they were trying to
curve the election for President Trump
if anything what the Russians are trying
to do is destabilize democracies and
they're trying to make the common or the
average American person think okay this
is an unfair or rigged system why does
my vote even matter and that's sort of
the stuff that I think was being
practiced and so those nine people that
were indicted again I could be wrong on
this and hopefully you guys will fact
check me but it seemed like it was more
related to what they were doing and less
related to collusion with the Trump
campaign but but again you know
all of this stuff is eventually going to
come out I do think the president will
be fully exonerated and if I'm right
hopefully they'll invite me back on
c-span and we can discuss why he was
fully exonerated then if I'm wrong you
can put a dunking station out here in
Southampton and you can dunk me in this
nice suit that I'm wearing the book is
coming out when okay so my book will be
out probably the first week of October
we have a minute or two left we'll go to
Kathleen quick question joining us from
South Dakota on the Republican line and
please be brief yes I would like to know
why out of all our government presidents
President Trump is harassed the most I
can say I didn't vote for Obama but yet
nobody is investigating how he tried to
destroy the United States as as far as I
know I feel and president Trump's just
trying to make America great again it
takes time when people mess things up
and create all this havoc in America for
somebody to come through and make it
right again Kathleen thanks for the call
we'll get a response from Anthony secure
Moochie well listen I mean at the at the
end of the day you know and I I went to
law school President Obama I have an
enormous respect for him and first lady
Obama but we just were very very
different politically and so you know
people get these jobs they try to do the
best that they can if they go with
nefarious activity like in the house of
cards and things like that I hope that
our legal process can uncover that as it
relates to President Trump he's being
harassed because he is an agent of
change he's not part of the
establishment and the people that live
in Washington on both sides of these
staff and Republicans and Democrats they
don't want what people like President
Trump they're they don't he opens up the
door for billionaires that are
left-leaning or right-leaning or
business executives to say well why not
me and you know I get it I understand
human emotion if you're sitting in
Washington for 30 years looking down at
Pennsylvania Avenue thinking you should
be sitting in the Oval
office and then some guy moves down
there from Trump Tower after 17 months
of campaigning you know you get a little
frustrated and you get a little
mean-spirited I get all that but again
I'd like to leave it on a very positive
no country I'm gonna lock on we'll try
to get back a moment there's some bad
weather here in the East Coast and that
could affect the signal but Anthony
scare much if you there just a moment
for your final comment and we apologize
for that go ahead I think we can hear
you if you can know if you could see me
or hear me I'm just saying we have a
phenomenal country we have an
unbelievable opportunity over the next
25 to 50 years let's dial back some of
the coarseness and the rhetoric on both
sides frankly and we'll get we'll get
there and a lot better mood
Anthony Sierra Moochie joining us from
Southampton New York and again we
apologize at the very end for the signal
issues but we appreciate your time we
hope you'll come back again thank you